[Music]
here at the things we are massive fans
of cartoons and we can't get enough of
them however there are some things in
some cartoons that were pretty big
secrets until they revealed themselves
keep watching to the end because we'll
show you someone from the loud house in
a way that you wouldn't have recognized
if you only saw the first season if this
is your first time visiting the things
then please give this video a like and
hit the subscribe button today you're
going to see 10 cartoon secrets finally
revealed Disney cameos here at the
things weird I can tick lifelong fans of
pretty much everything Disney has ever
produced if there's one thing the iconic
animation studio does well it's making
cartoons that appeal to its target
audience and beyond let's face it if we
told you to name an actually bad Disney
film could you do it we don't think so
the best you could probably do is a film
that doesn't appeal to you as much which
isn't the same thing at all but one of
the reasons why Disney has always been a
byword for quality and class is the
attention to detail with such an
illustrious history there are bound to
be some cool things that you might not
notice otherwise for instance did you
know that 101 Dalmatians features a
cameo from the title characters of the
Lady and the [ __ ]
that's right if you look carefully when
Pongo and Perdita are searching for
their pups you can see the two other
dogs in the shadows and more recently in
brave there's a witch who made carvings
out of wood you might not notice it at
first but one of them features Sully
from monsters Inc those are just two in
fact we think we could fill today's list
with great Disney cameos where's
Springfield The Simpsons is the
longest-running cartoon series of all
time starting in 1989 it's smart send-up
of traditional sitcom tropes made it a
massive hit and one of the many many
reasons why it became so hugely
successful was that the show was set in
a place that was both wonderfully real
and knowingly fantastic at the same time
the city of Springfield could be any
town USA but for some fans of the show
the real question was where was it
exactly one episode behind the laughter
said that it was in Northern Kentucky
but even then debate raged as to whether
that was canon or not what makes it
harder is that Springfield is one of the
most common place names in the United
States there are more than 40 places
with that name and four of them alone
in Virginia however while fans had
countless theories as to its location
there was one person whose opinion
should be given more weight than others
that's the show's creator Matt Groening
matt is a native of Portland Oregon
which sits next door to the city of
Springfield the 1950s sitcom father
knows best was set in a Springfield and
that made the young Matt think it may
have been the one near him so when he
created the Simpsons the name stuck
Shaggy's real name scooby-doo where are
you is one of the best-loved and most
iconic TV cartoons of all time the
stories of teenagers Fred Velma Daphne
Shaggy and their great day and
scooby-doo were smash hits across the
globe it was yet another classic cartoon
from hanna-barbera and it led to a whole
lot of spin-offs however there's one
thing that a lot of fans of the show may
either not have realized or else didn't
know at all and that is what Shaggy's
real name is if you don't know who
shaggy is he's the laid-back slacker
with the massive appetite so what was
Shaggy's real name the answer to that
question is Norville Rogers by the way
did you know that despite what a lot of
fans believe shaggy was only really a
hippie by accident
his original voice actor Casey Kasem had
no idea what a hippie was supposed to
sound like so he based his voice on a
character played by the actor Richard
Crenna in the 1950 sitcom our Miss
Brooks Moana and Aladdin we all enjoyed
the 2016 smash hit movie Moana Disney's
tale of a Polynesian princess who
travels the seas and saves her Island
from a blight with yet another success
from the legendary animation studio in
the title character we find a new
exciting addition to the pantheon of
Disney Princesses Moana was a great film
that opened up many Minds young and not
so young to different worlds and
cultures but what was the first Disney
movie to take its inspiration from
outside the stories of North America and
Europe we think it was Aladdin this film
was inspired by the Middle Eastern tales
of 1001 nights did you know that it was
directed by the same people who made
Moana so that might just explain why
there are lots of hidden references and
easter eggs too Aladdin in Moana for
instance both the genies magic lamp and
the flying magic carpet from Aladdin
appear in Moana by the way one of the
great things about Moana is that many of
the movies voice cast were of either
Hawaiian Maori or Polynesian descent
let's look at Moana
valo she's a native Hawaiian there's
also doing Johnson the former WWE
Champion is of samoan origin and has
been known to watch the country's rugby
union team sleeping Powerpuff Girls
when the Cartoon Network launched the
Powerpuff Girls back in 1998 they ended
up with a massive hit on their hands for
kids growing up around the turn of the
millennium the stories of Blossom
Bubbles and Buttercup were thrilling and
iconic the show features three young
girls who had superpowers bestowed on
them by their creator professor utonium
who spilled something called Chemical X
on that while he was making them in the
lab and the 2016 reboot which featured
new Powerpuff Girl Bliss is also well
worth a watch whether you're into the
original or not and like any highly
successful TV program the show spawned
an awful lot of fan theories there's one
that we like the sound of a lot we all
know the classic fairy tale Sleeping
Beauty right well have you ever seen the
Disney movie of that well in the classic
animation there were three fairies named
flora fauna and Merryweather and those
fairies wore red green and blue just
like the Powerpuff Girls we loved this
particular theory and we think that it's
a very smart secret to have it's like
they're giving a nod to some seriously
classic animation Maggie Simpson and the
price of raising a child seeing as The
Simpsons is the most successful animated
TV show of all time we reckon you've
seen a few episodes of it yourself and
if you've seen some episodes then you'll
be familiar with the program's opening
sequence but have you ever wondered what
it says when Maggie gets swiped through
the shop til it says eight hundred and
forty seven dollars and 63 cents that
isn't a random figure by the way as you
might just expect from The Simpsons
there's a story behind it when The
Simpsons was first made in 1989 a survey
said that the average cost of raising a
baby in the United States every month
was eight hundred and forty seven
dollars and 63 cents so that's a pretty
clever secret to put into every episode
we wonder whether Homer can afford that
working at mr. Burns's nuclear power
plant anyway maggie is one of our
favorite characters in The Simpsons one
of the things we like about her and it's
one of the many great running jokes in
the program is that she doesn't speak
well considering she's at most one year
old you'd expect that but of course the
Simpsons operates in a pretty flexible
universe with a pretty flexible timeline
so she has spoken in the program it's
just that she's never spoken in the
official time line in fact she spoke the
very first time the characters appeared
on TV that's right in the 1987 Tracey
Ullman Show short good night Maggie is
shown saying good night right at the end
Max's mother the single most iconic name
in the world of cartoons is that of Walt
Disney he was the founder of Disney
Studios the company behind so many of
the animations that we all know and love
not only that though but he was also the
creator of Mickey Mouse who is almost
certainly the single most famous cartoon
character around however he's not the
only Disney character who was highly
popular running him a close second is
goofy he's the good-natured if somewhat
dim-witted dog who's best friends with
Mickey with his long face and his orange
turtleneck he's instantly recognizable
what makes goofy interesting is that
he's often depicted as having a son Max
this is in contrast to an awful lot of
other cartoon characters who are usually
depicted as being aunts or uncles but
never parents the other thing about
Goofy's relationship with his son is
that he's often depicted as a single
father Disney themselves aren't entirely
sure who Max's mother is however back in
the 1950s
goofy had a wife we heard her voice but
her face was never shown it's entirely
possible that she was Max's mother
however there is one pretty bizarre
thing about mrs. goofy and that is if
you look at the parts of her body that
are shown it's clear that she's a human
Rick and Morty's secret we reckon that
if you were to ask a hundred people who
were born in the 1990s for their
favorite cartoon show the vast majority
of them would say Rick and Morty this
Cartoon Network show has become quite
the go-to place for Millennials to get
both their laughs and their catchphrases
part of the reason for the show's
success is that it contains multiple
layers of meaning whether it's talking
about science or philosophy or just
referring classic bits of pop culture
there's always a bit more to the show
than you'd think but there's also
something that some fans picked up on
and that's that the show's creators dan
harmon and justin roiland
wanted there to be a secret plot that
would be kept from the audience forever
they've admitted as much in an interview
not that long before the second season
of the program aired fans jumped at the
idea but couldn't quite agree what it
was we think that the best theory is the
sort of meta reference the show
specializes in and that's the idea that
Rick is perfectly aware that he has a
fictional character
think about it he breaks the fourth wall
he rode tests catchphrases it makes
sense we think Brian was human when
family guy first premiered on the Fox
Network in 1999 people went crazy now
Seth MacFarlane's fast-paced
wisecracking saga of the Griffin family
and their lives in Quahog Rhode Island
are firmly part of popular culture the
show's characters and catchphrases are
familiar to people who have never even
watched the program now one of the most
popular and certainly one of the most
interesting we think of the characters
is brian Griffin
he's the sophisticated talking cocktail
drinking jazz loving white labrador dog
that the Griffin family owns but here's
the big question how did a dog get to be
like that well usually that's the sort
of thing that happens in the cartoon
world's things and animations don't have
to make sense they just have to work
within the context of the show however
some fans of Family Guy came up with a
notion that turns the show into a pretty
dark place with at least one pretty dark
secret that's the idea that Brian was
originally a human since Family Guy
occupies the same universe assess
McFarland's other show American Dad and
that features a goldfish with a human
brain implanted it could happen it would
certainly make sense the loud parents if
you're a subscriber to the things and if
you aren't hello you should really hit
the subscribe button as soon as you're
done with this video you've probably
worked out by now that we're all
gigantic fans of the lab house but why
the heck wouldn't we be it's cool it's
funny and we love it but have you ever
noticed that in a lot of cartoons you
never get to see adult characters faces
that's right when you think about it
it's a pretty common trope and that was
certainly true in the loud house you
never saw the loud kids parents well at
least you didn't in the first season
well the characters of Lin senior and
his wife Rita were definitely there you
never entirely saw what they looked like
so it was a bit of a shock when the
second season of the loud house aired
and we got to see Rita and Lin seniors
faces turns out she's a nice pretty
blonde lady while he's a balding man
however we aren't entirely sure what she
does for a living nor do we know what
her maiden name is it might be important
considering that she's the only
character whose name doesn't start with
the letter L what's your favorite
cartoon secret that we've not addressed
today let us know in the comments and
that's it for ten cartoon secrets
finally revealed if you enjoyed it why
not check out
ten kids cartoon characters reimagined
as adults thanks for watching and don't
forget to subscribe
[Music]